it's super clever i mean the argument is
completely circular right yeah they just
say
you're a racist and you say well but you
have no evidence in my races and they
say well you don't even recognize your
own racism you say well then
how am i racist they say because you're
complicit in a system of racism you say
right but the system
isn't isn't racist like you can't point
to something that's right no but it
results in racial inequality
and therefore it is a racist system and
therefore you are complicit in the
system and therefore you're a racist
and you say okay well but all systems
perpetuate racial inequality
by even saying that you're demonstrating
your white fragility which means you're
a racist right like
this is basic salem witch trial if you
sink then you are innocent and if you
float then you're a witch
[Music]
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report quick reminder everybody to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
click that notification bell especially
especially on a day like today when i
have a guest
so dangerous that we're to get in a lot
of trouble you understand
the man sitting across from me that's
right it is ben shapiro
author of the new book how to destroy
america
in three easy steps here we go again my
friend
i know just get ready for it you get you
get it worse than i do i mean
honestly i'm okay my people will be fine
you're the one who pays the price do i
get it worse than you i'm not sure you
have a
very dedicated group of people at media
matters who
sit and wait for you to nod
or to move in a way that they can imply
is white supremacist i have a i have a
bunch of anonymous anime genderless
trolls on that
that's these are very different i have a
full employment program going over
matters i know we have at least one
maybe two people who are honest
basically full time at daily wires so
that's
that's exciting i'm glad that we can
create jobs in all sectors of the
economy
we are creating jobs i think the obvious
way to start this interview because i
want to focus on your book but
you know of course we have to talk about
some of the things i don't know if
you've heard there's a pandemic and then
riots have you
i missed all of this yeah you haven't
heard about it i know you've been out of
it
you're a busy guy um but you know i
titled my book
don't burn this book and then basically
the day the book came out
every store that had the book was on
fire
we didn't say don't burn the store to be
fair i didn't say don't burn the store
that
you know houses in the book now your
book is called how to destroy america in
three easy steps
it was about how to burn your book yeah
that's that's the the basic gist of it
but of all times america does seem like
it's being destroyed right now and
that's what you titled the book and i
know a little something about writing
you finish this book when how how long
december january
okay so actually not that one no this is
a quick right so what happened is that i
had gone to israel for the jewish
holidays i came back
and i just looked around the country and
i thought something is really really
deeply wrong i mean even more wrong than
it has been
in prior iterations and it's been wrong
for a while i mean there have been
things that have been going wrong which
is why i wrote
the previous book rights out of history
which was the country's kind of falling
apart
what do we do what common values do we
hold and then i thought well we really
need
sort of a nation-specific book about
what we're supposed to be sharing
because obviously
there's this widespread perception that
we share nothing right the only thing
that we share is an oppressive evil
terrible bigoted system
and so i come back from israel i called
up my publisher
i have a two book deal with my publisher
and my publisher i actually had another
book that was slated to come out
uh probably the beginning of next year
and i said i want to rush a book out
before the election
i want it to be called how to destroy
america in three easy steps and i'm
gonna write it in the next six weeks
and they're like do you write as fast as
you talk i do i i thank god
i write incredibly i used that was
actually uh little known ben shapiro
facts i used to uh
many there are many of them but one of
the one of the uh least well known as i
was a ghostwriter for many prominent
figures for probably
a decade and how i supplemented my
income so i have something like seven or
eight new york times bestsellers that
are not under my own
name i was really very specialist
publishers would come to me there would
be some prominent figure
who you know had three weeks to go until
deadline and they'd be like okay well
you've got
one sentence what do we do and they turn
me over the book and i'd write an entire
book in a month so that
can i can i get you to write a couple of
their names on the back of that paper
i'll tell you later
i'll tell you later not in violation by
ndas guys
in any case uh it was written at white
heat uh and it was
very easy to write because the structure
of the book is
is very obvious i mean the basic idea
don't we don't go that far yet i want to
talk
about i've got i i wrote down all six
chapters because i want to talk
structure because i think
i think the way you broke it down
actually is super interesting
um but before we do full book stuff
let's just talk about
the world as it is at the moment for
just a little do you believe on this
show
oh you can curse your brains out but
what do you mean you're you're a you
don't curse
i know but yeah i do if you promise me
i'll believe it then it'll curse oh
i yes my people will bleep it yeah
i've been waiting for that for a long
time shapiro because i've heard you say
off my guys don't have to bleep my
they can bleep your phone yeah
i've heard you say privately and
then you you put your little eyes as you
know as you know there is a bit of a gap
between
public persona and in private curse of
blue streak because you know so that's
that's not that's not a great shock but
yes okay so yeah let's let's just do it
for a little bit uh
are we like what the hell is
going on here right now um
it feels that way i mean it really does
feel as though any common bonds that we
once shared are basically
disintegrating and that you're being
pressured into
mimicking the belief that all those
bonds are gone so even if you believe
that the bonds aren't really frayed and
that really we should have some stuff in
common
if you say that out loud you're part of
the system you're part of the white
supremacist system
uh and this is it's such dangerous stuff
and as we're sitting here
very in the last few hours there was a
there was a
sort of graphic that came out from the
national museum of african american
history and culture which is a
smithsonian institute
taxpayer funded constitution by the
government funded by the government
and it was all about whiteness and the
evil's whiteness and among the evils of
whiteness things that we have all
integrated into our lives because
of the prevailing system of white
supremacy where things like hard work
individualism justice time management
delayed gratification science i'm not
kidding this is all in the document
these are all these are all things that
are listed
as elements of white supremacy that must
be rejected in order to move forward
into a better
more progressive world and so all the
things that you would think like yeah i
feel like we should all have this in
common like you know science
this one this one we should have in
common there's a whole movement to say
no no all of these things are outgrowths
of an evil
system and that in turn is a the result
of an absolutely despicable redefinition
of the term racism what it used to mean
in
for virtually all of human history but
certainly since the 1960s
to what it means now so in the 1960s
racism was what we all think of racism
as
believing in the inferiority or
superiority of a particular racial group
right very easy definition easy spot
wherever you see it right it's not not
hard it's very
easily applied definition and then
there's been an attempt in the last
several years to redefine racism to mean
any system that results in racial
inequality
is itself racist and so if you are not
seeking the destruction of that system
you are complicit in racism and in order
to be anti-racism
you have to seek to destroy that system
well every system in human history has
resulted in inequality of some sort or
another because human beings
have different capacities we make
different choices if you literally are
you telling me we're not
all exactly the same we don't have all
the exact same thoughts and gifts and
skills you're telling me
stop being racist stop it stop it so it
is slightly different
abram kenzie specifically writes this
right and how to be an anti-racist he
says literally any system
that generates racial inequality is a
racist system
and so therefore it's not like you're a
bad person because you're a racist
you're just a product of the system or
you're upholding the system
and in order for us to fight that racism
we have to fight the system itself
and so anything that is part of that
system anything and everything that is
of that system
is tainted by racism and must be ripped
down
completely and if you are complicit in
the system by by doing things like hard
work and individualism you're an
assimilationist right this is what this
is what
kenzie says and how to be an anti-racist
and robyn d'angelo sort of mirrors this
and you're saying to yourself wait a
second are you closing in an awful lot
of doors
to black americans and minority
americans like the pathways to success
in a free system are things like hard
work individual effort
you know thinking ahead delayed
gratification like this is not unique to
capitalism or the evil american system
or anything right but also what are you
saying about black people at that point
it's insane i mean david duke could
write this right i mean he really
could i mean david duke could write the
idea that whiteness
is about hard work and individual
initiative
and religious adherence and family
structure that's crap david duke would
write yeah but the anti-racists are
writing the exact same crap and they're
saying yeah but all those things are bad
right and if we just got rid of our
adherence to these systems well then we
wouldn't really have to have standards
that we hold people to
and then equality would be the result i
mean that's insanely dangerous stuff but
because the charge of racism is the most
is the most highly charged charge you
can make against somebody it's the worst
thing you can call somebody in america
and for good reason because
that is an awful thing to be right it's
an awful thing to say about somebody
it's an awful thing to be
because that is such a highly loaded
term
it's so easy to cudgel people into line
all you have to do is just
acquiesce all you have to do is be the
person who cheers on the guillotines as
the guillotines chop off heads
and we'll leave you alone now we're not
going to say that you're left alone
forever right
this only holds true until the time for
the next guillotine
i i really feel like in this situation
it's very much like the the action movie
where the bad guy comes to the good guy
and he's got some blackmail to hold over
his head and the good guy says well how
do i know you won't use it and the bad
guy goes
you don't you know right that that's
that's the anti-racist movement yeah
they figure that they can call you a
racist and they will hold that over your
head
until you acquiesce in all the things
and if you don't acquiesce in this one
little thing
then you will be ruined and you will be
destroyed and you will be targeted as
part of the opposition
and the good news is i think it is
generating some opposition from people
who are center
left i think that the only question for
the people who are kind of liberal
center left liberals
yeah you know the 153 intellectuals who
wrote that piece in harper's weekly with
the obligatory slap at
trump and trump supporters trump is
really the problem even though he's not
the one going to come burn down our
houses right the the the reason that
that actually matters is
first of all i'm glad they did what they
did i mean welcome to the party all
right i'm glad that
i'm glad that i'm glad they're doing it
but are you trying to broaden the
overton window just so it includes you
or are you trying to broaden the overton
windows such that we can actually have a
conversation because if the idea is
we only you know you lefties you're
mostly right about the things you think
are bad
but we just don't want you canceling us
so just leave us alone and we'll be okay
or is it going to be
you know you'll actually allow people
like dave reuben or ben shapiro or
dennis pregor or glenn or glenn beck
to actually speak and if the answer is
no then you really haven't added
anything to the debate all you're doing
is trying to
feed the crocodile so that ddt lasts i
sense you know my feelings on this yeah
i mean right they're protecting their
asses i'm glad that they wrote the
letter but the fact that they had to
make it clear we're not conservatives
we're not trump people trump is doing
this and it's like but
he's not the one that's rampaging
through your universities he's not the
one
out in the streets when they come for
all your mansions it's not going to be
trump and trump supporters i mean
we all know that so yes i think we know
what they're doing with the overton
yeah i mean that being said i still
think it's good at some level it's
better than that
the next step is i want to see some of
those people actually have open
conversations with people on the right
how about that yeah i mean why is this
what's amazing for both you and for me
is why is that
such a wild request like i have
conversations with people on the left
all the time and many of those people
will not come on my show because they're
afraid of being cancelled
yeah right and i and i know that the
same is true for you you've had
conversations with people all across the
political spectrum but many of them
won't have you on and
i know many of them won't have me on
because they're afraid of being
cancelled by their own folks
for conversations that we have privately
but they won't have publicly and
so then it's just okay you're just being
a coward at that point so we've sort of
talked about this a little bit before
but do you think there is a
fundamental reason for that that there
is a fundamental reason
that underlies the philosophy of someone
who broadly is on the left
versus on the right that why people on
the right are willing to do it if i put
someone
on the left on my show i put marianne
williamson on i put on andrew yang tulsi
gabbard
all the people on the right virtually
who disagree with them say hey you know
i disagree with her and him on this and
the other thing but it's glad yet i'm
glad you had the conversation if i put
someone if i put you on or prayer on the
lefties go bananas i'm i'm endorsing
white supremacy and
because i think that for the left and
there are many liberals who buy into
this
all all human relations are power
relations right you saw this in sort of
ezra klein's response to madagalesias
right how did i end up on the same side
as
matt iglesias man it's not the ralph
wiggum of the internet right like
how how has this happened but matt
iglesias had the temerity to sign that
letter and then ezra klein was like
there are a lot of people who stand up
for them
for free speech who are really doing
this because it's a way of gaining power
and for a lot of people this is on the
left is how they think of things right
all human relationships are power
dynamics there are no
big principles that we all share like
freedom of speech matters that's just a
bunch of people who are seeking to use
the principle of freedom of speech
as a weapon in order to reenact the
hierarchy in order to preserve the
hierarchy and this argument you see
being made more and more by folks on the
left which is that rights are not
actually
universal principles that we all should
hold to rights are just a way for me to
shut you up while i'm still speaking
right and that's and i i think that the
the liberal
left has been somewhat warm to that
argument for
for a while at least warm enough that
they were willing to hear it and they
just didn't see it turning
on them at any point the left moves so
far so fast that the liberals were like
we were with you up until the point
where you started canceling us
and then we realized oh wait that was a
that was a bad mistake right gracias is
one of the guys who's like cheering on
there's no cancel culture cancel the
cancellation doesn't exist
and then and then it came for him and he
was like uh
this is bad right guys it's like yes
it's bad
well yes thank you for recognizing it is
bad do you love seeing that now where
there's this move by them now aoc is
doing this and a bunch of other people
to completely tell us that cancel
culture it doesn't even exist
it doesn't exist when she's not
explaining that
that people are shooting each other in
the inner city for breath for bread
right that's
that that's that's why you should wear
her on their playground is because
they're hungry that's what i do when i'm
hungry
you know i say to my wife are we out of
cereal she says yes and i immediately go
and shoot somebody in the face that's
that's
the way i deal with my own personal
hanger right
but when she's not saying that sort of
stuff this is becoming a very popular
notion on the left which is that
all america is a group of people who are
dispossessed and the people who are
victimizers
and any principle that exists in the
system that is the victimizing system
again this goes back to
the kennedy point or the robin d'angelo
point any aspect of that system is
inherently bad and reinforces a power
hierarchy
and so you must remove those systems of
power in order to allow the dispossessed
to claim their full share of the earth
you're a sci-fi guy do you sort of
admire
the beauty of their evil you know what i
mean like really
at some people like to create a system
that that proves itself
that in and of itself is the proof like
there's a certain beauty to that oh it
hasn't as evil as it is it's super
clever i mean
the argument is completely circular
right yeah they just say you're a racist
and you say well but you have no
evidence in my races and they say well
you don't even recognize your own racism
you say well then
how am i racist they say because you're
complicit in a system of racism say
right but the system
isn't isn't racist like you can't point
to something that's right no but it
results
in racial inequality and therefore it is
a racist system and therefore you are
complicit in the system and therefore
you're a racist
and you say okay well but all systems
perpetuate racial inequality
by even saying that you're demonstrating
your white fragility which means you're
a racist right like
this is basic salem witch trial if you
sink then you are innocent and if you
float then you're a wedge
yeah all right so a lot of this actually
is very much the point of the book so
just quickly before we fully go into
that uh just
let's just do covid quickly sure like
where the hell are we at in this
let's just talk about california for a
second we just in the last couple days
went into another freaking lockdown it's
beautiful outside
i don't i i'm not sure what the beach
situation is whether we can go there but
i know i can't go to a restaurant
it's like what the hell is going on here
at this point what do you think is
honestly happening at this so i think
what's honestly happening is that you
have
a deadly disease that has probably
somewhere between
a two times and six times
deadly as an effect as the flu it's it's
somewhere between 0.2 and 0.6
uh infection fatality rate uh and that's
dangerous and it's very very infectious
and all of that is true the whole point
of flattening the curve was to prevent
the overwhelming of the healthcare
system we are not seeing the healthcare
system being overwhelmed right now
and so the idea that the only tactic
that is available is full-scale lockdown
i think is is not backed by evidence i
am also growing extraordinarily tired
of people shouting that they are on the
side of science while variously changing
their opinion literally every 15 seconds
so when masks are bad now masks are good
protests are bad with anti-lock-on
protests now protests are good and this
woke virus spares you so long as you're
kneeling for george floyd right
i mean think how bananas that is it's
crazy it's utterly nuts i mean that that
was
that was mind-bogglingly incredible de
blasio this week said that in effect you
are allowed to protest because racism is
so
systemic and profoundly evil that
somehow it supersedes the deadly virus
but everyone else couple orthodox jews
playing in a park in brooklyn
we got a problem it's a seriously woke
virus i mean good for colin kaepernick
who should win the nobel peace prize as
well as the nobel prize in biology
because
kneeling it turns out actually cures
coronavirus which is pretty awesome
that's incredible
but it's yeah i think that there's been
a bunch of false binaries that have been
set up and those false binaries are
things like it's either total lockdown
or total openness
it annoys me when people on the right
treat mask wearing as though it's like a
virtue signal and
it annoys me on the left when people
treat mask wearing as though it's an
incredible virtue signal you're an evil
evil
person if you're not wearing a mask when
you go to sleep at night and you're a
better person if you wear a mask
and on the and on the right there are
people for sure who are like well i'm
not wearing a mask under any
circumstance it's a violation of my
freedoms and all this kind of
like just when you're in a popular when
you're in a populated area with a lot of
other people
wear a mask it didn't that bad like you
should do it because you don't want
other people to get sick it's like
that's the best we can do at this point
in time with that said the idea that
we're going to full scale lock down the
entire american economy
or that we are going to leave children
out of school for the next year
because of covid like that seems
patently insane to me i mean
the reason it seems patently insane is
because the data are pretty murky on a
lot of
issues they are absolutely not murky on
the risk to children there is
so little risk to children if you're
under the age of 20 you have a better
chance of dying from the flu than you'd
have coveted i mean it's just a straight
stat
and what that means is that maybe we can
come up with some creative solutions
where parents actually have
a place where their kids can go for
schooling so
my friend john podhor is over at
commentary magazine i thought he had a
good idea he said why don't you keep the
schools open
and then you have a bunch of 20 year old
proctors and then you have the teachers
zoom in why the teacher has assumed all
the kids at home right why don't they
why don't you just
do it at school right that seems like a
fairly decent
idea but the the the incentive structure
is created
yeah for politicians to lock down
because the more sternly you treat the
virus
the better the media are going to treat
you right the more virtuous you are
right exactly and this is how you see
andrew cuomo who is a garbage heap of a
governor in this whole time and who now
creates magical posters tributes to
himself with literally a curve that
represents the number of dead bodies
in his state but being treated as though
he was great at this when his death rate
is like eight or nine times out of
florida where ronda sanchez is the font
of all evil and greg abbott in texas
it's like 11 or 12 times the death rate
in texas like
this none of the media coverage makes
sense the media there are a bunch of
issues here the politics of it makes no
sense the media coverage of it makes
some sense but it's a really ugly sense
because the politics have overwhelmed
the data
and then on a data level there's just a
lot we we actually don't know
at this point right we don't know
whether there's such a thing as t-cell
immunity that's
been one of the theories that herd
immunity actually may start to kick in
as low as 20 percent is a theory from
sweden
it could be at 60 uh we don't know
whether this thing is
how far away you have to be from
somebody did they say six feet but the
who was saying a meter until five
minutes ago by the way technically my
guy's measured we're seven feet away oh
yeah no and i insisted on that like
i'm a person who's taking this very
seriously right i mean like i i've been
taking it seriously i have 65 year old
parents so i'm not on the
let's be skeptical of all of this stuff
but the idea that like it's going to
wipe out vast swaths of the american
public and that
and that it's the most dangerous thing
that has ever existed on planet earth
and that we have to shut down the
economy
odd infinite here's the problem has
anyone ever actually done
on the on the lockdown side any analysis
of what the costs are on the other side
all i hear is if you mention those costs
then you're bad you know
right and that's that's insane like
these are public policy decisions and we
should obviously be having conversations
about how to protect the most vulnerable
and also how to trans people back in to
work i mean i've been saying for a long
time that it may
end up being that the way that we end up
moving forward is
what one i think is hebrew university
where tel aviv university scientists
suggested was controlled avalanche the
idea was
if you're most vulnerable you stay home
and we figure out ways to protect you
and if you're less vulnerable then you
go out and if you get it you get it and
then you're
one person closer to hurt immunity that
may be effectively
de facto what we're seeing anyway right
because this is let's be real about this
if you're 20 this is kind of how you're
treating it then this is where they're
going to say you want to kill people
that's what last time you were here you
were here for my book launch and then
the video you were the number one trend
on twitter
because you said we're going to have to
deal with some level of death it's a
problem we don't want to but that's just
reality
and then they came after you and said no
no no one should die in our perfect
right i
made the i made the very pure and
obvious which everyone
everyone understands the argument i was
making which is that if you're looking
at days of life versus just lives lost
that is a different calculation and it
is done by actuaries
every single day the federal government
has actuaries that do this on every
single policy
but again the the median narrative is is
very easy here
if you don't mirror the policies they
want then you're you're a grammar killer
who wants to murder your own grandma it
doesn't matter then i'm taking all sorts
of extraordinary
you know measures in order to protect my
own parents on this thing right so
all right one more thing on this then
which is without going too far down the
conspiracy
uh channel uh road
how much of this is that the system just
wants to destroy trump because i don't
think that none of it's about that
yeah i i think that in the media i'll
say it's mostly unconscious but i would
say a heavy percentage of it i'd say
over 50
is if a democrat were president it would
be how the president has handled this he
got the ventilators
everybody's doing the right things
everybody's trying this is an
unprecedented situation
if it's trump's fault why are we seeing
secondary spikes and countries ranging
from australia to japan to israel is he
president over there right we'd be
seeing that sort of narrative
we're not because trump is the president
so yeah i'm not gonna give any credit to
the media for for democratic governors i
think
all these stars align for lockdown the
economy is bad okay well
if i have to blame trump i'll blend from
i mean this is what cuomo's stick is
right that all problems in new york
state are attributable to the federal
government they're not attributable to
him the governor of new york state
yeah so i mean trump is convenient is a
convenient
thing to hit and and you get the added
benefit of maybe throwing him out of
office
and there have been those who predicted
that as soon as joe biden is president
that this will disappear from the news
within a month uh i'm not sure it'll be
quite that quick but i think that there
is a good shot that at least the
alarmism the the sort of
what we're steering in the dark without
a without any sort of oarsmen
okay that's true and guess what it's
true everywhere it's true everywhere
it's not just for in the united states
it's true in the uk it's true in france
it's true in spain it's true in italy
nobody knows anything okay and once you
recognize that
you realize that politicians may not
have all that much power to do
anything here because guess what new
york locked all the way down and they
lost 33 000 people
and florida didn't lock down as much and
they've lost like 4 000 people
colorado opened up at the exact same
time as georgia exact same time like
same week
colorado's case load is down 40 percent
georgia's case load is up like 100
so nobody knows anything so this idea
that like everyone's sitting there with
their slide rule and going here's how
many people i want to die it's just it's
not true
yeah all right with that in mind let's
talk about the book a little bit one of
the interesting things so you're talking
about
uh three easy steps but one of the
interesting things that you did with the
book there's only six chapters
in a pretty what do you how many pages
you got 250 something like that all
right
so first chapter when you talk about the
american philosophy
you think it's pretty good the american
philosophy what do you think the
american philosophy is you're radical
so i think the declaration of
independence pretty well expresses the
american philosophy it has a few key
elements right there's an idea that
your rights pre-exist government and
that government was instituted in order
to protect those rights so those govern
those rights adhere to you as an
individual they are given to you by
nature or god
right whichever you prefer and the idea
is that those are discoverable
in nature using our reason those would
be the right to free speech
the right to practice of religion the
right to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness right all of these are
embedded in the declaration of
independence so those
rights pre-exist government also a lot
of people
struggle with that but right and we'll
get here in a second what the actual
counter vision here is because
what we're seeing right now is two
separate and and very conflicting
visions of the united states and what it
ought to be
uh the the second kind of the second
element here
is the idea that because government was
instituted to protect those rights if
government violates those rights it
loses its raise on debt
so the idea is that government is
accountable to the people
and that the government doesn't have the
even if a majority wants it to the
government does not have the
the wherewithal to violate those rights
without undermining its own reason for
existence right that that idea of
limited and enumerated powers right that
we see in the declaration and in the
constitution
that's a central part of american
philosophy the idea that we are
that we are equal right the the quality
provisions of the declaration
of independence all men are created
equal now obviously jefferson
and they're the founders very clear
about this they don't mean everybody has
equal talents doesn't mean everybody
makes equal choices
it doesn't mean that i'm going to play
in the nba it's never going to happen uh
sadly for you it also means that you
will not be playing in the nba
i know but with with that said the idea
is that we all have equal rights
before government and before the creator
we have to be treated equivalently
by the law these people own slaves women
couldn't
vote how could this be right so this is
the countervailing vision of this oh
should we wait we're doing chapter one
right
okay sorry keep going and all of these
all of these kind of root
beliefs rights that pre-exist government
the idea that
all men are created equal and there's an
equality before law the idea that
the government is accountable to the
people but that even a majority is not
allowed to run roughshod over the rights
of minority right
all of these are then embodied in the
constitution which is designed with
checks and balances and enumerated
powers those are really the kind of key
provisions they're really kind of three
key provisions of the constitution when
you boil it all down
checks and balances enumerated powers
and federalism right subsidiarity the
idea that the best governance is local
because
you and i live in the same town we
probably agree more than i do with some
guy three thousand miles away i've never
met
the idea that that their checks and
balances because if i'm given ultimate
power i could be a tyrant if you're
given an ultimate power you could be a
tyrant but if we check each other then
we won't be running
not me not you you're awesome right i
for sure would be um
and uh and then the idea that um
so subsidiarity uh the the idea of
checks and balances the idea of
enumerated powers meaning the government
is given a very specific set of things
to do and does not have any power beyond
those things that was the
the goal of the constitution is to
provide the
the actual institutions that preserve
the rights that are talked about in the
declaration of independence
and this creates an explosion in liberty
not only in the united states but an
explosion of liberty that carries
throughout the world
now that sort of brings us to the
question of american history right so
we can go through i think the best way
to discuss it not to dictate to you no
but when it comes to the book i think
that there are three things that are
being destroyed one is the american
philosophy
and the second is american history so
the idea in american history is that
these founding principles were good
great they're universal
and that we've not always lived up to
them and the story of america is about
human beings falling short of principle
which is what human beings always do
human beings are sinful human beings can
be evil human beings do horrible things
to each other and so the story of
american history is us
seeking to live up to those principles
and then failing and then striving and
then succeeding
and that's a great story because that's
a story of triumph and it means that
we're all part of the same history even
if we're part of a victimized group
then we're the heroes of the story
because we overcame that victimization
to become part of this great chain that
is the united states to claim our share
of the american dream right i mean this
and i'm not the one saying this
frederick douglass was saying this as a
former freed slave
in in 1852 he was talking about how july
4th doesn't include us
but it should include us because
independence day was meant to apply to
everyone so are you going to live up to
your promises
or not or this is martin luther king's
promissory note the idea that we're here
to make good on the check that you
signed us
in 1776 and so american history is the
story of us trying to fulfill
those principles and getting better and
better at extending those principles to
a broader and broader
group of people which is a story of
triumph and not just extend those
principles internally but also extend
those principles around the world the
idea of free markets
and ownership of your own means of
production and
extending this around the world to free
billions of people from enslavement and
poverty
the idea of an america that frees
billions of people from abject tyranny
right that's an amazing amazing story so
the story of america is that america you
know president trump once said
you know slogan aired make america great
again but the idea of american history
is that america
always had great principles but people
are not always great so america was
always great if you think of america as
an idea
if you think of america as a set of
americans there are some who suck and
there are some who are great right
but the idea is that america was always
great it was great from inception it
just didn't live up to its own
founding creed and then finally there's
the idea of a culture that ties us
together and this doesn't mean that we
watch the same tv shows it means that we
speak sort of the same language
right that when i say write you know
inherently what i mean when i say
free speech we both immediately flash
you okay that means i can say what i
want
right when i say that there's freedom of
association means okay it means i get to
hang out with the person i want to hang
out with
if if we say freedom of religion it
means i get to worship in the way
that i want right these are these are
just clear-cut things that we agree on
ways that we discuss the world and a
culture of rights not just legal rights
that are enshrined a culture of rights
means that even
outside the bounds of government we
should respect each other enough to
acknowledge that we're going to disagree
sometimes right this is where we get
into canceled culture
because the idea is that and you'll hear
this from the left well you know we're
not
when the new york times you know oust
somebody or when the atlantic fires
kevin williamson or something
that's not that's not the government
doing it so what are you complaining
about that's just the free market at
work
that's true that's true it's not the
government but that only goes so far if
we don't have a culture where we
actually respect each other's ability to
speak
then culture always precedes what
happens in law
it's it's a pretty short leap from the
entire culture says a view
is is out of balance to let's make that
view illegal eventually
now that doesn't mean all views have to
be held in equal respects doesn't mean
there's no such thing as an overturned
window of course there is an overton
window but it does mean
you have to have enough respect for your
neighbor to say listen we're allowed to
disagree and
our rights mean that you're allowed to
misuse that right even if i don't like
the way you're using that right
the way to overcome your misuse of that
right is by using my rights to overcome
my right to free speech
to gather group people who disagree with
you and then we can win
right then we can then we can convince
you and convince the people around you
right that that's the way that rights
were always approached
that culture of rights has been
undermined so let's pause there for a
second because
we're dealing with this cancel culture
nonsense
right now do you think that there is
just a certain inertia
to movements like cancel culture because
of
because of all of the stuff that we
started this conversation talking about
that it's like we've had this thing
slowly building but now it does feel
like it hit the tipping point and now
it's just spread everywhere
do you think there's like a functional
reason for that yeah i mean i think that
there have been decades of an attempt to
rethink what rights actually mean
so one of the things that the left has
done is in the same way that we started
off by talking about the redefinition of
racism
they've redefined nearly every term that
we've talked about here
they've redefined every element of
american philosophy to mean almost the
precise reverse of what originally was
meant to me
they've redefined virtually all of
american history which is what the 1619
project is about
and they've redefined our culture of
rights so that rights are in fact
ways to oppress people right this is
when when we talked a little bit earlier
about the right to free speech being
seen as a way for the powerful to
silence the powerless and you see people
actually saying this kind of stuff
that's crazy i mean this is
in effect what right white fragility is
about this is in effect what all of the
the whole blm platform this is what it
is about like you're not just making
this stuff up no i mean
and when i wrote the book i didn't
realize that it was going to break
somebody open this way
i really thought that honestly when
coveted hit in march i thought okay i
wrote this book to rush out before the
election and now it's going to be
irrelevant because it's all going to be
covered all the time
and then all this stuff just broke loose
in the last couple of months and i
thought
wow i mean i'm not a prophet but if i
were but
but that's really how it feels i mean
looking back through the book
and realizing that all the arguments
that i was making against this
particular vision of america which i
call disintegrationist and the reason i
call it disintegrationist
is because i think that it really stands
for the the coming apart of america i
think that there's a group of people who
say here are all the things we have in
common
and as lincoln said we have to be
brothers because if we're not brothers
we're going to be enemies right that's
that's just how this is going to be the
better angels of our nature
had better win and we'd better all be on
the same page or we're going to fall
apart i think there's a group of people
who believe that they are the sole
exposures of ultimate truth
and as the sole expositors of ultimate
truth they get to club everybody else
into submission and therefore all of the
checks and balances should go away
because they are now the god-like
leaders
who know all the wisdom of the ages
they're the best people who have ever
lived
i mean this is incredible that they're
it's unbelievable they are better than
everyone that came here
what lucky people we are to be living in
this time this time
with such unbelievably special people
right who gets to rip down statues of
ulysses s grant and who get to suggest
that abraham lincoln was a bad man
whereas
they they would if they'd been living in
1863 they wouldn't have just been
abolitionists
they would have been people who are
arguing for for all end to segregation
and
and and complete mixing of people of
different races like
all the principles they hold today that
are good principles right all those
principles they would have held them
doubtless in 1863 with no background in
any of this stuff if they'd been born
all of their values are sort of floating
meiasmatically in the atmosphere
and they internalized them and they
would have been it wouldn't matter you
could plot them down
in rome in in 100 bc and they would help
exactly
the same values they exist outside of
time they exist outside of history they
exist absent to any other outside
influences they're just the most
incredible people who have ever lived in
the history of humanity good for them i
mean and good for us that we get to live
at a time of such things
it's so interesting because i've been
thinking about this a lot like if you
think about how fast it seems the world
is moving right now like just think
about today versus just
what we were talking about say 10 years
ago in 2010 whatever the hell it was
now if you take that further back and
you plop that person down in 1863
and try to imagine how different the
world is like people don't really just
sit in that for a minute
and realize how different it was without
plumbing and electricity and all of
those things and yet somehow their
entire moral code
would have been you know which they make
up
yeah it's it's quite they're not
standing on the shoulders of giants they
didn't learn anything from lincoln
american history has nothing to do with
their positions
they exist as free-floating moral actors
in the universe without any background
whatsoever they came to all of the
exact right conclusions about life
simply through a priori thinking it's
it's truly an
unbelievable achievement of the human
mind i think again we should we should
all feel very lucky
to be in their presence i mean the fact
is robert george he's the moral
professor
of professor of moral philosophy over at
princeton he says he uses this as a sort
of thought experiment he says okay so
alaska's class
you're living in 1860 in alabama are you
an abolitionist or are you pro-slavery
and everybody in the room
everyone says i'm an abolitionist and
then he's like really really are you
because i'd love for you to name these
extremely unpopular position you're
taking at the risk to your life
reputation and career
right now today like it actually risks
anything because none of you can name
any of them right
you're actually going along to get along
with most of your morality the example
that i like to use on this
is we're living in an era where
everybody thinks of themselves as as
deeply enlightened and all of this
100 years from now all these all the
statues of president obama will come
down why because he ain't made
100 years from now all the statues of
president obama will come down because
there's video of him
at campaign rallies you know in iowa
campaign stops eating a corn dog he had
that hot dog right and and
people are going to say
i'm with you on this it's the next
frontier of this lunacy and what's going
to happen is it's going to be
there were people who knew back then
that this was being mean to animals and
you ignored that sort of
that sort of suffering and worse that
means animals it's also destroying the
environment right
right you drove a car i mean there were
people who weren't driving cars you
can't say that you were completely
innocent in all of this
well nobody is completely innocent in
all of this the reason we erect
monuments to people is for the good
stuff they did not the bad stuff they
did
um but again when you think of yourself
as better than any human being who has
ever lived it gives you an awful lot of
moral authority to rip down everything
around you right so okay so we've we've
sort of veered into chapter two here was
which is when you talk about that
disintegration do you think that once
something
starts disintegrating at a certain rate
that then it's inevitable that it will
disintegrate because and that's sort of
what we're i think a lot of people are
feeling that right now like
oh my god the world really has shifted
the conversation has shifted
it feels like everything's out of
control
can it actually you know if the wave has
started can you actually turn the wave
around i mean i think the only way to
really turn the wave around is to
re-familiarize ourselves with principles
which is a difficult
task i mean we've we've basically
assumed that freedom was in the water
for 50 years 60 years and it turns out
freedom was not in the water kool-aid
was in the water
and people have been drinking into
university campuses and they've been
reading howard's in for a while
and now they think they have a very
sophisticated view of the world and and
so it takes some some
education in american history and
american philosophy to really
re-inculcate that but that's a hard
that's a hard slog i think it's gonna be
a rough time here i
don't think this is gonna i think
there's this assumption on the part of
liberals like good-hearted liberals who
actually believe a lot of the stuff in
the book because this is not partisan
right i
really believe that everything that i've
said about american history and american
culture like rights are good
and the declaration of independence all
human beings are equal before the law
like this should be
pretty consensus stuff i mean this is
not right left or centered i know a lot
of liberals who agree with this yeah but
i think that
there's this assumption that because
everything is trump polarized that if
biden is elected that all this sort of
goes back to normal everybody calms down
it goes away i think they are really
underestimating an ascendant left that
sees
the that sees the wave of history behind
them and they also see a weak actor in
joe biden they feel like they can push
him around and i think they're probably
right about that
i mean the guy's got serious problems
it's like that's the scandal
right like isn't that the scandal that
no one will talk about the scandal which
is that obviously something's wrong with
him
i mean it's it is pretty incredible that
that's considered such an out of bounds
opinion i mean the people like how did
without any evidence you're suggesting
that he's on the verge of senility i
mean i don't watch the tape of him like
eight years ago and then watch a tape of
him today and
joe biden was never any great shakes but
he looks like a different dude i mean
and then listen
you can elect him if you want i mean
that's that's your prerogative all right
but recognize that there's a high
likelihood you're also electing as vice
president
right so okay so we we started talking
about culture and i wanted to pause you
in the middle of it because when we talk
about culture
ben someone's gonna say you're talking
about american culture that's chapter
three but
american culture must mean white culture
that's what you really mean
shapiro is that it's about white culture
right and this is this goes back to this
whole
anti-racist idea which is that rights
themselves are a vestige of a white
supremacist system which
ignores all of the progress not only
made by black people but made by black
people
in the name of right in the name of
rights martin luther king saying
we ought to have the same freedoms that
you all are guaranteed
our freedom of speech matters no less
than your freedom of speech an american
is saying
because you're making that argument not
the argument the entire system is bad
not the sort of early malcolm x argument
that white people are devils and the
entire system is garbage
and all of this the stuff that he
abandoned later in his career you know
because you're making the actual
american argument yeah we'll give that
we'll give that a hearing that makes
that makes sense to us right i mean this
is the argument again being made by
frederick douglass he wasn't saying
that july 4th is bad he's saying we're
not included in that promise we should
be included in that promise when you
invoke
the deep principles of america you are
like your movement is likely to see
victory right this is the same thing
that happened with the gay rights
movement the gay rights movement said
listen
you guys are guaranteed freedom of
association you're guaranteed freedom in
who you love right so it was a rights
argument now i may not have agreed with
the application with regard to behavior
but
the the actual rights with regard to
marriage with the actual
early argument which was everybody
should basically be left alone that was
a very
robust argument it had a lot of power
behind it because most americans went
yeah that makes sense to me i mean i
have that kind of freedom why shouldn't
that guy have that kind of freedom like
why not
yeah right which is a different argument
than some of the arguments we're now
having which have moved beyond the
rubric of rights into
well i can demand from you a good or
service right right that's a bit of a
different thing
and by the way uh as you know we've
discussed this a million times this
that issue of the gay rights thing was
one of the first things that really
sort of broke me related to what was
happening with the right how the right
was being tolerant
because all i get is this endless hate
from the the he
him she her z whatever tolerant people
in the name of diversity
i just get endless hate from them and
yet here i can sit across from you we've
done it a million times already and it's
all been seen a gazillion times before
but
and it's like yeah here we are and we
live in the same country
right arguments have an innate appeal
right people in america
have always responded to rights argument
not everybody at every time but overall
the chain of american
history is americans recognizing that
arguments that are based on rights are
good arguments
now the left is abandoned arguments
based on rights they've argued they've
made arguments based on either
entitlements like you owe me x yeah
which is not you owe me you leave me
alone
you owe me this specific thing right or
the argument that writes themselves
are again and this is so pernicious
rights themselves are reinforcement of
an evil hierarchy
and that is so unbelievably dangerous
because what that leads to is
now we get to we get to encroach upon
your rights in order
so that we can get rid of the hierarchy
right this is an argument that's first
made by herbert marquis who's a
neo-marxist
uh philosophy professor uc berkeley very
very influential guy in the 60s he's the
creator of make love not war
and one of his big ideas was this idea
of what he called repressive tolerance
meaning tolerance for he literally says
this tolerance for opinions from the
left
intolerance of opinions from the right
because if you tolerate opinions from
the right then the right
the people on the right might win if the
people on the right win they're going to
use that power over you so we have to
actually stop the right before it gets
started
and we do that by curbing their right to
speak freely sounds like basically every
professor at harvard for the last 30
years yeah i mean and it's every fascist
in history which is i know the road to
utopia and it runs directly over your
house right it runs directly over your
your rights
yeah and so the argument that's now
being made that all rights are
essentially just
vestiges of power relationships and
their covers for
for evil racist arguments that if you
say freedom of speech what you're really
saying is you don't want to hear from
this black guy it's like
that is not only a nasty and scarless
accusation it's also incredibly
dangerous because you have now conflated
the idea that individuals have rights
that cannot be encroached upon by anyone
with the idea that those people are
somehow supremacists yeah are
you worried that within the cultural
aspect of this that
as we're seeing population shifts now
the amount of people moving out of new
york city
people moving out of california they're
moving to texas and then they're going
to turn texas blue and then
we've got a whole other problem but as
we're seeing
sort of the idea of federalism in play
right the good part of federalism so
people are taking responsibility for
their lives
that it's going to come at a cost that
our cultural
unity is going to really be ripped apart
because we will all just move to places
that are more in line with us
and then it's like well what the hell is
the point of the union well that's
exactly right i mean i think as we
polarize and it's not just
you know states which i think are
getting redder or bluer i mean this is
one thing that we are seeing purple
states are sort of disappearing
they either turn redder like ohio was
turning redder yeah until last few
moments
uh and and iowa was turning redder or
they're turning blue or like colorado or
virginia
right as the state's polarized that's
going to be a problem it's going to be
even more of a problem in just everyday
life
so yes california is blue and texas is
red but what happens when companies are
either blue or red
right when you're the head of goya and
you say a nice thing about trump and
suddenly your company is verboten
right now your company is bad and we're
going to boycott your company listen i
wear nike shoes right i think that
they fit my feet well i like them good
whatever
but you also like the repression of
speech in china come on
one of my favorite things but it but but
nike's but
it never at no point you know before
they started overtly
signaling on politics did i think to
myself i really wonder how phil knight
voted
yeah right it never occurred to me it
never occurred to me to say you know
what i'm i'm looking at this apple
computer i really do tim cook's
principles match my own principles
it never occurred to me to do that
because the idea was okay he's providing
me a good or service that i like
his politics have nothing to do with it
and good that's how we should live
because we can also make spaces they say
made in cupertino oh no no they say what
do they say designed in cupertino they
don't tell you where it's made
that's the genius of what they do but
yes that sort of endless
uh polarization of everything and the
politicization of everything makes
things so ugly and it makes it so that i
mean i got mocked online for this
i said like i'm gonna i'm gonna find it
harder to watch the nba this season if
the nba has black lives matter on the
side of the court
because again the offense in black lives
matter is not the actual phrase of
course black lives matter it's perfectly
obvious
the whole point of painting black lives
matter on a court is to suggest that
there is a vast
swath of the american public for whom
this is not obvious you're not painting
on the side of the court
babies are good right like we all kind
of agree babies are good it would make
no sense to paint that the minute you
paint black lives matter on a court what
you're really saying is and there's a
bunch of nefarious people we don't like
wink wink not not trump supporters
who don't believe black lives matter
when you when you're saying that you can
put a slogan on the back of your
of your nba jersey i don't want to see i
i really i don't want to see defund the
police
lobbying in an alley-oop to raise taxes
like that's
not my that's not my thing by the way
this is literally
uh a policy of the nba now there's what
is it about 20
phrases that they'll social justice
right now in hong kong
you can't do free hong kong right that's
what you can't do they won't let you
even make it right as a fan
but but you're not making this thing up
i mean they've they've allowed for about
20 phrases that are social justice
phrases so that you don't have to have
james on the back of your uniform so
what you'll inevitably end up with
is people who are like yeah but i still
like basketball and they'll start a
basketball league that's like the
patriotic basket i don't want that i
want to be able to share
basketball with people that i disagree
with i want to be able to watch
tv and understand that i'm not going to
be sucker punched just for
the fact that i tend to believe in lower
taxes and more personal freedom like
doesn't it suck though in some way that
we really were ahead of the curve on
this i don't mean that to paddle
but but literally people can watch the
same conversation three years ago or
four years ago we were talking about how
as politics infects everything it is
going to destroy everything
that if you every time you turn on espn
if it's about race or it's about
politics
it will have destroyed sports and we're
there you know i have a great idea for a
show you want to do a show together how
about we will watch
this is what i do for cardio anyway we
will watch old nba games together
and do play-by-play we'll do
play-by-play
you want to do color or play by play you
talk that so you got to be play by play
and i'm calling yeah i think it's
probably right yeah we got to do it that
way
i'm not i that's what i do for cardio
watching 90s bulls games with jordan is
way more interesting than when they
bring this thing back and i got to hear
about
all the political stuff i don't feel
like all the common spaces that we had
where we weren't being lectured are now
being taken over and then militarized
and this is one of the things i do talk
about
in the book with regard to corporations
so there's this widespread perception
corporations are right-wing they're so
conservative they're right-wing
corporations are profit seeking
enterprises if you are the squeakiest
wheel and you
suggest that you're going to go after a
corporation the corporation will
probably cave to you
and so what the left has realized is
they can do this on any variety of
topics
right they can go after coca-cola and
say you know coke
you really shouldn't appear on facebook
because facebook allows people who are
right-wing on there and coke's like
listen i don't
i don't have a dog in this fight i don't
really want to get involved i just want
people to drink soda right exactly
that's my thing and so all of the people
who wanted to stay out of the fight are
now in the business of virtue signaling
to the left because the squeakiest wheel
gets the grease well eventually
what's going to happen and it's going to
be bad is the right's going to fight
back the exact same way eventually the
right's going to say listen
if you don't give us the messages we
want we're not going to patronize your
company
right we're gonna we're gonna be the and
by the way you see companies that are
doing great business specifically based
on this model right our friends over at
black rifle coffee
we're doing exactly this kind of
business right they basically said we're
the anti-starbucks starbucks is your
woke progressive
sjw coffee and over here you know what
we like we like guns we like freedom
we like the military drink our coffee
and people like sounds better to me
i guess i'll do that yeah and they're
killing it and they're killing it and
that's what that's
gonna happen there's gonna be two
companies for it now can there be a lot
of money made
there sure but does that further
polarize the culture in every single way
it polarizes the culture you're not
going to be able to live next door to
somebody who you disagree with without
suspecting they're trying to get one
over on you
and this is also where the left all
these things cross streams right the the
destruction of the culture the
destruction of the history the
destruction of the philosophy
these all cross streams because once you
destroy the culture and all the
commonality
then you know what's a really important
thing at that point all the checks and
balances of the government
right because that prevents 51 percent
of the population from cramming down
their perspective on the other 49
so naturally the disintegrationist would
love nothing better than to ditch all of
the checks and balances ditch the united
states senate ditch the electoral
college
get rid of all those things we'll just
have a pure majoritarian system and
we'll just
ram down and get rid of federalism we'll
ram down from the top
this one and once you do that then the
risk of
the country really splitting becomes
incredibly severe because with 51
percent of the population you can say to
me that you're going to tell me how to
raise my child
forget about it and there are hundreds
of millions of people like me i would
think so you have a line i think it's on
page three of the book about that
basically the way we look at the world
is that is that viral picture from a
couple years ago that either you see the
dress as black and blue or you see the
dress as
gold and white is that really what this
is now that we are
we are at the point that i think about
20 of us tried to stop from happening
for a couple years there were maybe more
than 20 of us but a bunch of us tried
online to stop it from happening
that this thing was going to happen no
matter what
and that basically we're there now and
we both just see a different dress
and to actually bring that together you
already hit on it
in a certain way we have to go back to
some of those principles and things like
that
but in a certain way that maybe if you
factor in the internet and just the
pervasive nature of wall culture
it may be an impossible uh project
it might be it might be the only way
that you bridge that gap between how you
view the dress is by saying
hey maybe we can see this in different
ways and still agree to be friends and
then that
i think is the one thing that the
disintegrationists do not want above all
because if we all agree that we can
disagree well then maybe i might
disintegrate
i might convince some of you and you
might convince some of us we might have
a conversation
and we might leave each other alone and
recognize that we're human beings so the
key is the
the polarization is the point it's not a
byproduct yeah the polarization is is
the feature not the body
yeah oh god and it's really it's really
depressing but
the the point that i'm trying to make in
the book is that when i say this stuff
about the declaration or the
constitution
when i talk about checks and balances or
equal rights before law
when i say this stuff i feel like most
americans i'm not talking about a silent
majority i mean like most americans
period basically agree with this stuff
and
they've just not recognized that there
is a threat to these things
because what the left is so cleverly
done is what i refer to earlier they've
really shifted the language so it went
from
i have a right to free speech too well
you know i have a right not to be
offended
he's like well no that's a very
different use of the word right
right the the word right typically meant
that you have a right
not to be encroached upon by me you have
a right against
me doing something bad to you you do not
have a right
to violate my ability to speak freely
because some unspecified
harm may at some point attend upon you
you don't have a right to my stuff you
don't have a right to run my business
you're never right to tell me how to
raise my kids
right the redefinition of right from
something i had that pre-existed
government
it was a thing i had a pre-existing
government and i had it against all
other people
to i have a demand of you and i wish
that demand to be honored
so redefining right as a demand is a
very clever trick
so but do you let's give the devil a do
here do you think and i know we have to
separate the leaders of
this thing from the the foot soldiers
but do you think they believe it when
they tell you
words are violence but then they'll also
tell you burning down a business
isn't violence because it's not a you
know you're not murdering a person
although i suspect if we burn down their
house they might think it's a violent
act
do you think they genuinely and honestly
believe what they're saying or that
they've just outsourced
uh their faculties i suppose to to the
greater cause
um i think there's some of both i mean
i'll grant them either one ends with the
same kind of conclusion there's
authenticity either they're
authentically
believing or they're authentically
stupid or both um and i i think that
there's
some of both i mean i think that there's
a there's a certainly an element of the
narrative matters a lot more than this
particular fact pattern right this is
the aoc line about how
you know why are you so focused on
whether i'm what i'm saying is true or
not
it's really it's the overall message
that matters right i think she said it
has to not be factually true but morally
right but morally right right
that is the line of the ages right here
and you can see it
very clearly in the in the 1619 project
right the 1619 project is like the best
example of this ever
where the title essay includes the
preposterous claim that the
that the revolution was fought to
preserve slavery which is pure insanity
i mean like there's not a shred of
evidence
whatsoever to support this claim like
none zero zip zilch okay and
this thing was given the pulitzer prize
yeah and nicole hendon jones doesn't
give a damn about the truth i mean she
really does not
the the entire project the 1619 project
i talk about it at length
is replete with just ridiculous claims
that have nothing to do
with fact and an incredibly reductionist
view of the universe in which everything
is simply a reflection of underlying
american racism there can never be any
other rationale for a bad thing
happening
everything bad that has ever happened or
is happening is a result of racism there
are no other intervening factors i don't
know if you know the answer to this but
has any other nation
more quickly gotten rid of slavery been
formed as a nation that had slavery and
then gotten rid of slavery that quickly
answered that question actually
we got to be in the top five but i mean
things that people don't know i mean
saudi arabia abolished slavery in 1961
right i mean the the
the british empire only abolished
slavery in its own colonies in the 1830s
qatar is using slave labor right now and
somehow al jazeera
is is a uh so this is not to justify
slavery in the united states but it is
to recognize that like
history is a thing that happened and
also there are lots of other things
happening on earth
it's one of my big bugaboos is people
looking at the united states in a vacuum
and then you look at somebody in a
vacuum and of course they look flawed
any individual they like
this this happens to a lot of people
when they're dating because they look at
the person they're dating and they're
like it starts off and you're really hot
and heavy on this you're like oh this is
fantastic
and about three weeks and you're like
yeah but dwight do i like her nose i
like his
and then you think about it you go yeah
but of all the other people i know this
is like the best person it's the best
one
right but if you look at anybody in a
vacuum you're like god look at all the
flaws look at all the flaws here and
that's what people
tend to do with the united states
they're looking for flaws and so when
you're nitpicking and looking for flaws
you don't have to nitpick to find flaws
in the united states but when you when
you find flaws in the united states and
you refuse to even
like look across the pond and say wait
is there a comparative case here
like is it possible like when people
will make the claim that the united
states was an imperialist colonialist
power
and stole all the land that it's sitting
on it's like well what were native
tribes doing to each other like for the
several thousand years preceding that is
it possible
but actually seizure of land is one of
the universals of human history
is it possible that slavery was one of
the evil universals of human history
and the united states was very
instrumental in stopping slavery and in
fact fought a war in which 600 thousand
americans died
in order to end slavery like the putting
things in context is actually
quite useful but it's one of the things
that people on the left really don't
want i mean nicole hannah jones has said
this
right nicole hannah jones said that
you're not supposed to say
about jefferson for example that he was
a man of his times
or ulysses s grant that he was a man of
his times because she says well hitler
was a man of his time pol pot was a man
of his times like
i'm pretty sure hitler was not a man of
his times the exact same way that george
washington was a man of his times
i really in 1939 i don't think there
were tons of people on planet earth were
like you know what let's just massacre
six million jews for no reason at all
but slavery was a universal of human
culture for all time that's not an
excuse
for evil what it is is a recognition
that human beings progress beyond evil
as part of a chain of history
when they learn from the past and when
they stand on the shoulders of other
people nicole hannon jones in her belief
that slavery is bad
is standing on the shoulders of people
who believe that slavery was bad
and that was a process of learning for
all of humanity not just in america i
mean slavery
again when i say it's universal i mean
it is universal slavery was in africa
there's still slavery in africa in parts
of africa today slavery was in latin
america it was in south america it was
in europe
i mean there is there is no culture on
earth of which i am aware that slavery
was never practiced
at the very least among warring tribes
so the this idea that the united states
is the font of all evil right the new
york times ran a piece where they said
that the
most the most durable
cast systems in history were india
nazi germany and the united states
insane that's patently crazy you have to
be so ignorant of anything remotely
resembling history to make that claim
but this kind of stuff is cheered on at
the new york times yeah well all right
so let's actually do the new york times
for a little bit here as long as we're
doing it because as we're as as we're
sitting here
this new york times thing has burst into
the world uh full disclosure we both
know barry
okay i'm friendlier with barry than you
are i think i guess so but barry
weiss was the opinion editor who wrote
the original piece on the idw which you
reminded me right before we started that
you weren't even in which was psychotic
but there's a reason for that you
weren't in it
because you're a scary conservative and
the farthest
she could sort of push it was basically
me and jordan
and maybe michael shurmur a little bit
something like that but then the rest it
was good
liberals and i remember finding it quite
bizarre because i was literally on the
stage when eric
coined the term idw was like yeah i was
in the audience
yeah but she she wrote i actually think
you can link a lot of what's now
happened at the times right to that idw
article because it was it was her way of
trying to inject the last bit of
liberalism and
true liberalism into the paper she got
demolished for it she tried she threw me
under the bus because you'd have to be
uh what was the line um
uh something or you have to be you'd
have to be cynical or
stupid to talk to some of these people
on the right that was a shot at me and
rogan but more so me um and then by the
way i just tweeted this out and i don't
like all these little silly things
but she just david just reminded me that
two years ago at dinner after the
article she apologized to him about what
she did with me and said she was forced
to do it
by the editors that ties together i
don't mean any of this for insider
baseball or to gloat but she has now
stepped away from the times
and it seems like it's a true pivotal
moment
that maybe to now link this to your book
because i'm a hell of an interviewer
uh is now the dec the full-on
disintegration of the new york times
that we've been calling for years
but do you sense now that this is the
thing oh yeah the core meltdown
no question the inmates are in charge of
the asylum barry stepping away is
actually sort of the
the second bomb to fall right the first
bomb was james bennett the opinion
editor there
getting fired over the great crime of
printing an op-ed from a sitting united
states senator on an issue where over 50
percent of americans agreed
yeah right that the the law and order
yeah i know like oh my god we should
stop riding and looting a threat to the
safety of staffers at the new york times
they're literally tweeting this
safety isn't out i mean it was
crazy they were they're tweeting out
stuff like
you know the tom cotton's op-ed is
threatening the safety of nicole hannah
jones like really does she feel unsafe
today does she
really with her pulitzer prize sitting
there shining in the corner and her
six-figure salary from the
bastion of liberalism that is the new
york times yeah barry's letter is very
very good i mean
barry's letter which basically details
there's there's so many lines in it that
i think are worthy of note
and are so true but the the one
paragraph that really i think
goes to what we're talking about is it
used to be that there was a belief
that journalism was about the collective
enterprise of truth-seeking
and that meant that we were all supposed
to argue with each other and we were
supposed to turn over the rocks and see
what was underneath and
examine all of the sculptures from a
different angle feel the elephant from
all the different angles so you know
it's an elephant and not
either a snake or a rat or a tree right
i mean like that that but
what she says is that orthodoxy has
replaced that this self-righteous
orthodoxy where we are the keepers of
all knowledge
and we will cram down that version of
knowledge on everybody else
that has now become the cause at the new
york times that is perfectly obvious
that's been
quite obvious for for quite a long time
that truth takes backstage to all of
this
very simply saying it out loud and then
people at the new york times saying how
cynical of barry weiss to do this
that's not true barry just deserved to
go because she's a weakling
all these same idiots who are saying
things like you know what we need to do
we need to rename the washington
redskins
in order to rectify the past injustices
of the united states
i'm offended by washington redskins but
barry weiss that weakling being offended
by people in internal slack channels
with her editors
posting her name with axe emojis it's
like well okay hold up a second
i'm perfectly willing to hear you in the
washington redskins thing like i frankly
don't care about that
very much although i will say that
native americans are a lot less offended
than the wolf white liberals who are
interested in getting rid of the name
washington redskins bi-polling data but
with all of that said
like the idea that barry's a weakling
while you guys are out there saying that
the term
master bedroom should be removed from
the lexicon because it is reminiscent
of slavery or that like master and slave
units
on on you know electronics need to be
removed because it's reminiscent
of your great great great great
grandfather who is enslaved on a
plantation in alabama like
really who's who who's who needs to to
buck up a little bit here
right so should we be feeling pretty
good about things then because we were
kind of right i mean
or it is at some level this goes to the
institution thing i mean
you're gonna need institutions in this
new world no matter what so it's like
you'd like some of them to exist itself
yeah
right so i think that clarity is good i
mean to you know borrow from prager i
think the clarity is is definitely a
good thing so i'm glad that the masks
are off i think all the masks are coming
off simultaneously which is quite
frightening right
that i guess is the weird part normally
they sort of slip gradually and right
now it's like mass mass mass and they
all drop simultaneously like whoa
i didn't realize this is that weird
party from that tom cruise movie yeah
this is a weird place man very very
weird eyes wise shut
yeah exactly you got it um the yeah that
that
is in of itself sort of frightening
what's gonna have to happen next
is what we were talking about a little
earlier the people who consider
themselves
liberal and are very angry at the
censorious culture are going to have to
acknowledge that the overton window has
to be just not not just them
right that's the next step they won't if
they if they don't then
then it really is over right i mean if
you if the people who signed that
harper's letter
still say that they can't talk with you
yeah or they can't talk with me
or that they can't talk with glenn not
even they agree with any of us or think
that we're wonderful human beings but
they can't talk with us
or say he's a nice guy i am now too
scary for them
the idea because you know what it is
it's also i think this is sort of one of
the things i've been thinking lately is
there's a reason that so many people
hate
liberals and you know why it kills me to
make that statement but it's like this
this self-important world view that it's
like they would
never i don't mean this for every single
person that signed the thing
of course we're being sort of brought
here but they would never
ever want to have to admit that holy cow
evil ben shapiro or evil dennis prager
glenn beck or whoever was right and and
i think that
hubris is actually they would rather
sync with the ship
i think ultimately and maybe that's
right i mean that's why again that
harper's letter all they had to do
was find one person who voted for trump
yep one and there were 63 million of
them
right they could have even found people
who didn't vote for trump last time i
mean i would have signed that letter if
they had taken out some of the
silliness about the right-wing
militarizing canceled culture
against cancel culture and all this kind
of stuff but the but the fact that they
could not even see it in their purview
do you think it's that they couldn't see
it or that they intentionally didn't you
know i think they intentionally did it
yeah
okay i agree with you i think that it's
intentional because i think they knew
that if i had signed on to that letter
half the people who signed it would have
dropped yes
right they could have noam chomsky who
literally defended pol pots cambodian
genocide
but if they put somebody like me on the
letter or any of the other people who
like
again it drives me up a wall because
i've defended so many of these people
i've done it publicly
i've put i've put my own you know
resources behind them i've called them
privately to offer them support
the number of these people who will text
is my happy birthday test will text me
happy birthday but will never publicly
say happy birthday for fear that i will
it will then be known that i was born
and was born a human being
yeah that maintains and as long as that
maintains there ain't
no come back to the cancer culture
because they're part of it they just
disagree with the boundaries of it
yeah again i'm not saying that there
aren't people
in society who you know have views that
are so far out of the
out of the mainstream that you that dave
reuben doesn't have to host them right i
mean or that i don't have to
have a debate with them or something
like i think that that's perfectly legit
i'm a person you're a person we all get
to make that standard for yourself
exactly my window is pretty damned wide
and their window is pretty damn narrow
they better widen that window real fast
yeah so it with all that in mind though
you've got to be feeling pretty good
about the future of the center right
right
yeah i i think that the future of the
center right is pretty is pretty strong
i think there's a weird time for it
because everything has been so
trumped right everything is about trump
i mean i do talk a little bit in the
book about trump i really
it's pretty spare um but but what i what
i do say about trump is that i think
that people
need to understand the other side's
perspective on on what trump is so
people on the left see trump and they
see he's vulgarian he's nasty
he breaks all the rules he's he's a bad
man who says terrible things about
people and he's a jerk
and he's crude and all this kind of
stuff and they say i can't vote for
somebody of that character i think okay
i mean all right fair all right okay
fine and then
people on the left have to acknowledge
what many people on the right see in
trump and what they see in trump is not
saint wonderful human being what they
see against him is just the only person
right now who is standing in the bridge
that's literally it i agree the one guy
who will do it the only speed bump
that's there
to slow down this thing for like half a
second and
so kind of doing this routine that the
left does and that they did that
harper's weekly letter which is if you
voted for trump it's probably
because you're you are trump and it's
like well no actually
people are voting for trump and voted
for trump last time and many will vote
for him this time
despite all of the mishandling and all
of the battery and all the tweeting
because in the end if the debate is down
to make america great again versus
america was never great which is the
argument that the hard left is making
i think most americans are more in line
with make america great again
then america was never great now biden
is doing that smart is he's trying to
allow the debate completely right ryden
biden is smart enough to recognize that
playing dead and then
being very milk toast in his own
opinions is
the best way to win victory right he's
offering no he's he's offering nothing
hard
for trump to push back again so he'll be
asked about monuments and he'll say i
think the confederates should come down
but we should leave up columbus and
washington and jefferson like that's a
smart thing for biden to do
but he's not going to be a bulwark
against this stuff right and well and
also it is
him doing that is sort of the liberal
assigning that letter right it's like
just the temporary move to make sure
you're okay while they tear down
everything else right and again like
i think there's a decent argument we
made for removing confederate statues
like they're not heroes of mine i don't
think they were heroes when they were
fighting like i
i get that but you do get the feeling
from from biden
that he's doing that more as a political
ploy than he's doing that out of
pure unbridled enthusiasm for the
american family you know what it reminds
me of you know how many times i've told
you that we've debated abortion in here
and that
i always say to you it's not your good
arguments that have moved me it's the
bananas
left right eight-month argument i'm
having that with the
statues now because i used to say my
preference would be you leave them all
up and you put a
counter plaque or something right but i
kind of moved on that at one point i was
like you know what
to build bridges here you can put them
in museums and then you have right you
know
do your multimedia things about them and
all that but now they're going to burn
down museums right so again it's like
this is not the good arguments that move
me in many ways it's
it's the ridiculousness but once you
doubt the authenticity of the actual
agenda then it's like
all bets are off right then i'm not
gonna then then people are gonna say i'm
not budging an inch
right because and i feel the same way
about the policing issue right so
originally when this thing started it
was like well sometimes the police are
brutal with people and that's bad
i was like all right i feel like 193
percent of americans agree with that
yeah i think
there's nothing inarguable about that i
think most americans also agree that the
cops are
generally doing an amazing job at
keeping law in order and most cops are
standing between you
and vicious villains on a daily basis
but sure there are cops who are who are
brutal and go past the line and there
are a few things we can do about that we
can curb qualified immunity in certain
cases we can
dispense with some of the the procedures
of police unions right we can we can see
if there are better training programs we
can
make it easier to fire bad officers and
get a federal registry of of
fulfilled complaints right we can there
are things we can do and so
if you listen to my early podcast during
this george floyd thing
a lot of it was on this it was like okay
well here's some stuff that we could do
if we actually want to do something
and then it turns out that all the left
wanted to do was
root for rioting and looting i mean
nicole hannah jones literally
said that she was celebrating the fact
that people were calling these the 16 19
riots
celebrating writing and looting talking
about how it wasn't just about
curbing bad behavior it was about
defunding the police and how the police
were actually just the modern day slave
catchers
about how law and order need to go by
the wayside which by the way is going to
end with dead black people it's already
ending with dead black people in new
york city 100 of the people who have
been shot in new york are people of
color
100 not 95 100 okay and
and so once it moved beyond that i was
like okay you know what now you don't
like screw off like
you were never legit about this in the
first place you're not looking for
common ground you're not looking for a
solution
you're looking for again a reinforcement
of the idea that everything about
america is
inherently terrible and inherently bad
and i'm not going to go along with you
on that i think a lot of people are
having that reaction so
i think it is fair to make the
simultaneous arguments that if there
were to be a good faith debate about
confederate statues then i could
definitely see my way clear to saying
things like
i don't see why confederate statues
should stay up but if it's being argued
by the same people who are like
every statue of the american founders
must come down and they must all be
replaced by statues of nicole hannah
jones i'm like well you know
i'm gonna go no on everything and also
i'm not interested so that really that
really is the rock and the hard place
then because the more that they do that
the more that just average people who
are just not particularly political even
they just have to say no we'll never
move on anything i mean it's too bad
that trump is not a better vehicle for
the resistance right i mean
in 2016 there was a feeling that he was
that he was sort of a backlash to some
of these things that were happening
and then it turns out that
he's just so easily distractible that he
doesn't have the ability to focus in on
this like
if you told me that there was a
republican president
against whom there were essentially race
riots or with related
that there were race riots on the basis
of tearing down
statues of washington and jefferson and
defunding the police
and that this president somehow
was not gaining pull credence from this
while his opponent was hiding in a
basement
and the entire democratic party was was
half
rooting for the looters and writers like
how
how like th this is one argument that
i've been having with some of the folks
who are you know
very pro-trump and again i plan because
all the factors we've talked about i'm
voting for him because me too he's the
only he's the only stop gap at this
point
but that does not mean that if he loses
it's not on him if he loses on him i
mean the media is a pre-existing
condition
uh the the democrats are preexisting
if you somehow lose to a dead man in
a time when you can literally say that
your opponents are supporting the
burning down
of churches in some cases and are and
are
spending their days trying to defund the
police while painting giant murals on
fifth avenue
then you know i if you if you are losing
my 13 points to that i
that's got to be i knew it at a certain
point see it's interesting because i i'm
with you on that except
to me the polls are polls in the last 10
years or at least in the last five years
let's say in the age of trump have just
become completely meaningless
at this point not all i don't mean pew
polls on on opinions but i mean on
presidential politics i think they've
become completely
national the national polling last time
was pretty good yeah and then the one
thing that's happened the difference
between 20. wait what do you mean
you mean in 2016 it was 20th but but the
state level polling in wisconsin and
michigan was obviously bad
and and pennsylvania too the national
polling was within 0.5 percent of the
actual outcome
so when they say that trump is out by 10
yeah that's
he's not he's not by two if he's out by
time right the thing that i can't get
over though is that it seems to me if
you voted for trump in 2016
i can't see many people going all right
i voted for trump in 2016. maybe things
aren't exactly as i wanted them to be
but i'm going to vote for biden and
tearing down statues
and burning things and everything else
so i don't see many of those guys moving
but i could see an awful lot of people
who voted for hillary
going the party's gone completely
bananas and at least hillary had an
excited base
i think i mean this literally i can't
find one human being
excited for joe biden joe biden i am no
expert on this i called it wrong in 2016
just like everybody else
professed to have data still it was such
a joy to be with you that night
it really was hilarious
the problem is that he's not running
against hillary 2016 was a referendum on
hillary it was not a
referendum on trump she was unpopular of
the voters who despised both candidates
and that was something like 10 to 15
percent of the population
they broke very very strongly for trump
the same poll done today shows them
breaking strongly for biden and that's
specifically because
of the one advantage that joe biden has
that trump does not which is that joe
biden is dead
joe biden being dead is his greatest
advantage do you think they're going to
debate
uh no actually yeah i think not i think
i think if i had to put money on it
uh i would i would say very unlikely
because i think that
what's the point for biden i think that
he'll just say you won't turn over your
tax returns
we're in the middle of a pandemic anyway
what are we going to do like skype
debate
it's going to be too weird i think that
if you're leading by 10 or 11 and he can
actually cite the he can actually cite
trump on this right i mean trump
actually
just didn't do a republican debate in
the middle of the in the middle of the
last election cycle
because he was insulted by megyn kelly
or something so he can actually say
listen if it was good enough for trump
it's good enough for me
i think that biden's strategy here is
the dracula strategy you stay in the
crypt
until night falls and then you come out
and i think that that's
that's not a bad strategy because again
he doesn't make people the problem for
trump
is that it's very difficult to make
people feel like joe biden is secretly
rooting for the rioters because he's
so just nothing he's just so nothing now
if he
nominates for vp kamal harris or
something if he nominates for
vp tammy duckworth but it's coming right
i mean one way or it's going to be one
of these people right like that's how
they have him hostile
i could see a world where he nominates
somebody like susan rice who is who's
more
known as like foreign policy person yeah
even though she sucked at that and was a
liar
to boot i could see him doing something
like that i think that'd actually be the
smartest
pick just double down on the obama of it
all um i mean if you could get michelle
he'd win 83 states right i mean
everybody sort of acknowledges this
states that have not yet been invented
he would win michelle obama joined the
ticket but
with that said you know his you know
biden's greatest asset is the fact that
he's inoffensive
and in a time when trump wants to be
able to point to the democrats and say
look at all this crap they're doing
biden's been sitting in the basement
going yeah i don't really like rioting
and looting so much
and yeah i kind of like the washington
statues and that's the tenor of his
campaign
and what that does it throws the ball
squarely in trump's court which is earn
the vote
i've said for forever trump is great at
one half of politics and horrible the
other
politics is about make it hard to vote
for your opponent and make it easy to
vote for you
trump is very good at the former and he
is awful at the latter right how many
suburban women do you know
who are like yeah you know i'm gonna
bite the bullet and i'm gonna vote for
this guy even though
he's just black yeah right and i i don't
know
very many at all i i also think there
were a couple breaking points for a lot
of people i think coveted was one of the
breaking points
i think honestly the writing and the
looting were kind of a breaking point
for for a lot of people
not against the left but against trump
in some ways because it was like oh so
i'm just not seeing it so i i i'll say
that i've gotten a lot of letters from
here and i don't want to be too
anti-trump here because again i plan on
voting for him but the
the i got a lot of letters from people
who are saying
he's the president where is he you can't
just tweet law and order
you have to actually implement law and
order what is he doing he's out there
you know befuddlingly tweeting about
nascar while the country is burning but
what did they what did they want him to
do because in many ways i think this is
what i actually was just on dana parino
today talking about this that
i think the mayor of portland and of
seattle all these places they want the
cities to fail
so that trump is forced to bring in the
national guard or something like that so
he will
look like the hitler that they want him
i mean that may very well be true but
the fact is if you're going to
run on a law order agenda at a certain
point you have to actually instill law
in order
i mean the the setting executive order
saying we're going to prosecute people
who tear down statues you know a month
after the
after they shut down the entire city of
los angeles at 6 p.m every night to let
people riot
like what he should have done is he
should have said
after the first riot he should have said
listen you guys have
24 to 48 hours to make sure that your
city is secure
i offer the full resources of the
national guard at that point i'm
standing in the national guard
and you are going to deal with it we
have we have legal processes in these
countries
in this country for handling objections
we have a democracy we do not have a
dictatorship of the mob
and so if you're not going to handle it
i absolutely will and i think that
frankly i mean you were here during the
riots how many
los angeles law-abiding los angeles
would be like that damned fascist and
how many would have been like
you know i'm kind of glad i can go out
of my house at 6 30 at night again no it
was scary there's no doubt it was scary
it's so interesting and this is why you
can't judge it all by meeting someone on
the street an email because
i'm telling you just walking my dog
around the street a lot of people are
coming up to me and saying i've been a
democrat my whole life
and i'm voting for trump and i'm buying
the guns
and all kinds of stuff now again no it's
a bubble in la it's a weird place and
everything else but
i i desperately hope you're right he's
gonna need to make up at least some of
the ground because i don't think you can
trail in every single swing state and
then pull it out at the end
yeah um so he's gonna need to make up
some ground bullets and there's
there are ages in politics i mean i'm
old enough to remember when bernie
sanders was gonna be the democratic
nominee and the stock market was it near
30 000. so
and by old enough i mean i'm more than
four months old
is that the depressing part of this
though that that in many ways the
progressives did win
like the the idea that there's an old
school democrat
putting dead biden i like that i like
that uh
as a rule i like the dragon again right
right exactly
but that in effect yeah they lost the
election this time but they they have
won everything they they demolished the
democratic party they're
you can't point to me but please do if
you can ben where
is any decent democrat where is jfk
where is daniel patrick moynihan where
where is any
they're few and far between i mean i
think that they've tried to ask them in
primaries
um nancy pelosi and door still had omar
for re-election
the other day i mean this is not any
great shock i think you're right i think
they've captured the democratic party i
think more than anything
the right focused on the wrong things so
you know i talk in the book about
culture
the right uh speak more broadly about
culture the right
never had the wherewithal to compete in
the cultural space
or in the educational space and so they
basically seated the ground and then
they said you know what we'll win it
back at the ballot box right
we'll elect republicans republicans have
been elected in
several recent presidential elections
2000 2004 2016.
they held congress all the way from 1994
to 2006 and then they held it again from
2010 to 2018.
and they held the senate for wide
stretches of that time
and the country continued to move to the
left the country continued to move the
left and every way
and that is because the institutions of
popular culture and the media were
totally taken over the great lie that
republicans kept banking on
is that reality would eventually kick in
for folks right the idea was
and i know this because i've been
operating on campuses for a long time
i'd go and
you also wrote a book about it yeah
that's true but but i mean just from
operating on campuses one of the great
things that would happen is
my very first book which i wrote when i
was 19 was about liberal bias on college
campuses and
one of the most frequent questions i got
was well why are you
talking about college campuses who cares
about college campuses and i was like
it's not going to stay on college
campuses
and people said no you know they'll get
out in the real world and then
they'll have to be hired they'll have to
work a job they'll have to learn to get
along in the workplace
what if they bend the real world to
their will what if the person who
graduated the journalism program at nyu
goes on to the new york times and isn't
inculcated into a culture that values
freedom of speech
but is granted the keys to the kingdom
and told it's your turn to redefine the
meaning of journalism
and that's what's happened and the right
basically
did nothing the entire ship of state has
been listing to the left and meanwhile
the republicans are running up the
running up the slope trying to plant the
chairs
on this side of the titanic well it's
it's still listening guys you're going
to at a certain point you're going to
have to fight back
culturally i think that's frankly why
trump was elected because he's seen as a
culture guy not as a governmental guy
uh and then are you saying we're the
violinist on the titanic you're a
violinist yeah
so you're definitely one of the
violinists that makes me japanese women
and children first
yeah and how you find women shapiro
we've done about an hour and a half here
i know you've got a lot going on have we
i think we actually sort of touched on
almost
almost everything in the book is there
is there anything else that you want to
talk about while you're here uh
not i mean i think we covered a lot i
think that the the you know the the main
thing that i would just recommend to
everybody is do your reading
if you do any reading about the american
founding if you do any reading about
our culture if you read the constitution
and declaration and you don't come away
with tremendous admiration for
the ideas behind it and at least a
little bit of respect for the people who
wrote it
if your idea of your own self-righteous
virtue
is that you're tearing down statues of
people who did more in their lifetimes
than
you have done in yours then you really
should be thinking
more about what you are as a person and
less about what people who died 250
years ago were as people considering
you're standing on their shoulders and
propagating the principles
that are important to you watch this
shapiro because you're a professional
i want you to look at that camera right
over there and tell people
where they can get the book how to
destroy america in three easy steps
by moi you can get it over at amazon.com
i believe we are still putting out
signed copies as well at dailywire.com
go check it out today if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell